David Flanagan
here. Let's take a dive.
Tonight the spotlight's
not on the host you see.
It's on a piece of tech meets Spice
DB.
Fine grained permissions
done the modern way.
Gonna unpack
it all starting today.
Oh,
Spice
He'll share the insights,
show us how it's done.
The power of Spice DB
second to none.
Raw code live
with
Alright. Hello, everyone, and welcome back to Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, Rawkode, sometimes known as David
Flanagan. And today on Rawkode Live, we are
taking a look at another exciting open source
project called SpiceDB.
And I'm really excited for this. I wanted
to do an episode on this for a
while because this is something that I have
personally implemented
badly at nearly every job I have ever
had, and that is authorization.
So today, we're gonna see how to do
this right.
And to guide us on our journey today,
I am joined
there we go. From Jimmy, cofounder and CPO
at Offset and maintainer of SpaceDB.
Hey. How's it going, man?
Good. Good. Thanks for having me.
Absolute pleasure. I like I said, I'm really
excited for this episode. It's a great piece
of tech, and I'm looking forward to showing
people how to get started and hope to
be successful. And
I can only imagine the amount of times
I've seen permissions and authorization done badly in
my life that you must have seen a
whole lot more. But before we get into
that,
could you just take a moment, say hello,
and introduce yourself to the audience?
Sure. Hey, everyone. I'm Jimmy Zelinsky.
I'm one of the cofounders of a company
called OpZed.
I'm sure we're gonna get way deeper into
that in this this call, but
I guess my background is just both in
product and engineering as a software engineer for
many years,
mostly working in kind of like background kind
of cloud native ecosystem,
just kind of as it all emerged
And, I kinda transitioned as I had more
opinions on how things should be architected
into more product leading role.
But, yeah, I have worked on a bunch
of, like, main projects in the CNCF space
and then also,
I'm an OCI maintainer. So that's the standards
for containers.
Awesome. Thank you so much for sharing all
that.
Alright. Let's talk about SpaceDB then and give
people a bit more, of a background of
understanding than what they're gonna see today. Right?
So
I said SpaceDB is their authorization.
Right? And then I'm assuming
this is something that, you know, maybe not
all projects, but I'd say a large percentage
of projects need to handle permissions of some
sort in their application.
And, yeah, I wasn't lying. I've built this
wrong so many times in my career, or
at least I've taken a rather naive approach
to permissions. And SpaceDB,
especially when you start to play with it,
it reveals so much about why I've been
wrong in my entire career. And I'll share
more of it as as we go, but
maybe you could give us a bit of
the background. Right? How did you end up
in this space? Why is the Zanzibar paper
inspiring in this open source project? And how
can we do permissions? Like, what is the
landscape of permissions that you've seen in your
past and where we are today? And that's
a lot. Sorry. I just threw that right
at you, but, you know, good luck. Yeah.
No. That's a great great kind of intro
context laying.
Kind of as you were saying,
I personally have also
seen every rendition of kind of authorization or
permissions implemented
across a bunch of different applications I worked
on in my career.
And
the reality
for this is there's been years and years
of research in the authorization space,
but there's not really a strong cohesive
narrative in the space or best practices that
are well described in
a way that most developers are educated.
So when it comes time to build this
part of the functionality for your application,
a lot of folks just don't really know
what to do. They hear their end customers
throughout terms like RBAC,
and they kind of have used other applications,
something like GitHub probably where they they know
there's like organizations and teams and roles, and
they could probably model something just similar enough
to that.
But I guess,
just taking a step back, my background and,
like, the the main project that kind of,
like, inspired
most of our work transitioning to work on
SpiceDB and founding Offset was
actually
Quay, which is the first private Docker registry.
So,
my cofounders and myself worked on that back
in the day and this was before kind
of Docker even had any, enterprise or way
to store images in a registry privately.
There is only the public index of images
that people could share. And when you think
about it, the core differentiating feature, like the
main feature between
Quay at the time and kind of like
the open Docker index
was authorization.
That that was it. The ability for you
to make images private. That was the core
functionality.
Everything else was just kind of layering on
kind of nice to have, but where,
where rubber meets the road and where people
what they were paying for ultimately was the
authorization scheme built on top of the standard
container
registry.
During that journey, we realized there were some
features that
the juice just wasn't worth the squeeze to
implement
the proper
security primitives in our authorization model to even
ship those features.
And even to this day, a bunch of
those features have never shipped in Quay simply
because it would take too long to really
go through with a fine tooth comb,
the custom code we had built and,
kind of
cohesively create a new model, test it, build
our confidence in it, get security auditors in
there so they can look over it before
it ever gets deployed to, an enterprise environment.
Right? And, it just takes really senior engineers
to kind of go through that. There's very
painstaking progress or a process, and there's time
to be spent better elsewhere on the project,
building out some other more important feature.
So sometimes you just get into this little
rut. They're like a local maximum.
The features you can actually build just based
on your authorization system.
And we just kinda looked at ourselves, and
we're like, there's gotta be another way. Right?
There's always a better way to do it.
And that was largely when Google published the
Zanzibar paper,
and that paper kind of models the system
that Google designed
internally. This was originally actually to drive kind
of the functionality in Google plus if you're
familiar with that.
And
the the really interesting thing about Google's paper
and the reason why I think it's, like,
more novel than a lot of the other
kind of authorization authorization research that came out,
mostly
because it talks about a cohesive system.
If you go and read papers on authorization
or even blog posts, you'll hear about RBAK
and ABAC, and they'll talk about this concept,
these ideas
for how you can organize stuff, but they
won't tell you, like, this is what a
comprehensive
deployed real world system looks like built with
these ideas.
And the Zanzibar paper is that. It's actually
kind of a retrospective
paper
looking back on the system they built, how
it scaled, how how they ran it in
production for a while, the things they have
learned,
and it gives you the holistic perspective to
kind of understand,
what goes into a robust authorization
system and the framework that drives it. So
I hope I did a good job answering
your question.
Yeah. Definitely. For sure. And then I think
it leads us in nicely as we kinda
explore SpaceDB in more detail.
But I'm also gonna come back to my
my failures throughout my career because I feel
like there's a certain pivot point where you
realize just how important
correct offset permissions are in your application because
they're not something that are easy to fix
retroactively.
And I'm I'm sure if that resonates with
anyone that been in in my position, hopefully,
maybe your position at some point too. Right?
But let's assume you start off with a
simple application and you start off with a
simple RBAC model. Right? A user has some
sort of role and that role has permissions
across
everything in the system. That's typically how I
used to do it. Right?
You say a user is an editor. They
can edit articles. Job done. Right? You never
really take it any finer grained than that.
And then at some point in my application,
we decided, okay. Well, actually, people are gonna
have multiple roles because we can have editors,
but you could also be an admin and
you could also be this. And this is
where we go from this flat one to
one mapping of roles to users.
If you were silly enough to build it
that way, which, of course, I have many
times.
And then you you start getting fancy. And,
again, I'll lean on my own experience where,
like, why don't we just store an integer
and where they, like, shift some bets for
every role and then if that bets active,
you'd and then it sounds fancy and it
sounds cool and then you realize you're in
a world of heart later on.
That doesn't scale either. But then you're so
ingrained in this model
that whenever you want to do anything that
is truly sophisticated and goes beyond the simple
RBAK premise, it fails substantially.
And this is I don't know if there's
a certain point where or a type of
system maybe this is a a good question.
Right? Like, at what point do you need
a SpaceDB verity just flipping a column in
a database? And the example I had in
my head is, like, fine. If you've got
a flat system with user rules and content,
fine.
I think it be again, the quick example
is perfect. Right? You've got user
generated content,
and their permissions are not gonna be something
that is
easily baked into the system as a whole.
I don't even know if I'm explaining this
correctly, but there's definitely a point where SpiceDB
and this model and the Zanzibar implementation, all
of this comes together, and it's like a
eureka moment. And I wish I had it
sooner, but I didn't. And yeah.
Maybe you can kind of get this, like
but
I'm gonna keep just talking at you, then
you can just keep nodding at me. But
let's try and find our actionable question here.
Where do you see think I know your
question. Your question is, like, when do you
introduce something like a SpiceDB in in a
project. Right?
Well, I was actually gonna make it simpler
to start and lean into that. Right? Should
every system use SpiceDB? Let's start with that.
I think the answer to that is no.
Right? If you're if you're just building an
MVP of your app, like, you you're a
startup founder and you're trying to test to
see if an idea has product market fit
and you're really early into the process,
I do not think outside of a couple
niche kind of domains,
so say you're,
trying to build a healthcare startup or something
like that, where you're gonna have more sensitive
authorization logic, things where you're like managing
when doctors are assigned to particular offices in
these particular hours. They're allowed access to this
customer information,
like or this patient information.
If you know there's something like that, you
probably wanna invest in SpiceDB really early on.
Otherwise, if you're kind of building a standard
SaaS app, the very beginning of your project
when you're kind of, like, trying to find
your initial customers, things like that,
it's just not the right time for something
like this. Like, you're gonna be writing a
lot of code you're gonna end up throwing
away later. And I think the the point
is you should be focusing on kind of,
like, figuring out if your product is gonna
succeed.
But there comes this kind of phase of
when you're developing your product
where the customers are gonna start coming to
you, probably enterprises depending on what software you're
building, and they're gonna start asking for things
like, hey. We're trying to model our, like,
structure of our business so that we can
have multiple teams inside your application.
And I feel like once you get to
that point where,
the customer feedback is flowing that you need
better kind of organization around your resources
and the permissions that are maybe trying to
sink in even,
that's
when you need to start evaluating something like
SpiceDB or other authorization tooling because now you're
kind of it's it's not just like, okay,
we've proven out our idea. Now it's looking
at it as like an investment into the
future of the product and giving yourself
a foundation
that you can change
and maintain the velocity with which you're developing
your application. Because if you end up building
something yourself, it'll probably work for a little
bit, but also you're not giving yourself kinda
like that foundational piece that you can mold
in different ways. So you're gonna build something
really brittle, and then you're gonna throw it
away and have to rebuild it. And then
you'll build the new thing also brittle
for the new requirements, and then you're gonna
throw that away eventually when you get even
more requirements. Right? And it's just rinse and
repeat.
And
folks don't as they're building their application, they're
not thinking about how to make,
the most robust authorization
foundation that's future proof for them, that's gonna
be easy for them to maintain over time.
That's something that only people working full time
on authorization systems think about.
So really,
I think it's at that phase where, like,
the customers are coming to you asking for
these things that you need to consider, like,
okay, I need real tooling for this that's
that I'm going to invest in and invest
in my product over time. And and that's
that's really when I would say start looking
at something like SpiceDB
or plenty of the other tooling that exists
for an authorization. Just don't build the stuff
yourself because I think that's where people fall
into the trap of hurting themselves over and
over and over again.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you.
So you mentioned,
you know, SpaceDB is inspired by the Zanzibar
paper. You've kinda touched on that a little
bit. Maybe we could go into a bit
more detail, you know, for the people watching.
What is different from, you know, the naive
implementations I talked about versus what SpaceDB
is doing. Like, how do people make that
cognitive shift from, okay, I know this to,
okay, I need to start doing this.
Yeah. I think to some degree,
the most naive take people have when they
build authorization themselves
is they probably store
some data in their database. Like, say they're
building a Rails app, they're gonna do what
they do with everything when they're building a
Rails app. They're probably gonna use their the
active record ORM
to model some some tables that they're gonna
store inside their database and they're probably gonna
pull that data down when a request comes
in and then they're gonna execute some Ruby
code that has custom logic in it to
interpret that data to say like, alright, is
this person allowed to perform this action?
And kind of the major problem there is,
like,
the the data that gets stored in the
database,
I never told you anything about structure or
shape. Right? And then the logic written in
Ruby, never told you what any of that
logic actually is. And those are both gonna
change a lot over time.
And it's gonna be a lot of complexity
management around that.
The other question that you have in this
this kind of system is
that it works when it's a monolith, but
like you start introducing microservices
and now that data lives inside of the
monolith database.
But say you have another service and it
needs to check some of those permissions.
What you end up doing is, like, you
build this ad hoc permissions API into your
monolith. And now that's, like, not great because
the whole point of microservices is to get
the monolith out of the critical path. Right?
And, like, kind of break down pieces into
orthogonal components.
But now everything has to check preflight things
to the monolith before it can do work.
So you kind of get into this place
where,
it's definitely not gonna last you forever. Right?
And so the Zanzibar paper says, alright. You
you could abstract
the code that you've written in your monolith
and pull that out,
and use it as a library, but still
doesn't solve that problem, that data living inside
the monolith database until you have a centralized
kind of authorization
service at your business.
So the same way you would make a
microservice of other domains, why don't you have
a microservice that's dedicated to checking permissions?
And what's really cool about that idea
is that can be shared across your entire
product portfolio.
It's not just used for one particular app.
So that means you can implement these really
interesting experiences.
So say you're Google, and this is a
real example. If you're Google and you, if
you
open up Gmail and you paste in a
Google Doc link and then try to email
it to someone,
Gmail will actually preflight a request to Zansbar
that says, can the email recipient
actually see,
like, do they have access to read this
Google Doc?
And
Google Docs
has no idea.
It doesn't share any code with Google Drive.
There's there's no kind of shared logic there.
All it's doing is is sending a request
to Zanzibar saying like, hey, does this email
have access to this URL?
And
you get to build these deep experiences. That's
a really powerful experience. Actually, if if you
say like if it finds that the person
doesn't have access, can actually remediate it then
and there in in Gmail
as well. So you can give people access
without
the back ends having any shared code, which
is kind of crazy.
But you can build these super deep integrated
experiences once you have all the permissions kind
of living in a centralized place. Another example
would be like, if
you are an engineer at Atlassian building confluence,
you could write rules like if a Jira
ticket is embedded in this confluence page, if
someone has access to this confluence page, they
should inherit access to the Jira tickets that
also live inside of that page. So now
you get kind of like this really,
nice kind of cross
product unified
view of kind of permissions across your product
suite.
I just don't think there is many other
solutions
in the space that give you that kind
of experience
and give you that kind of central central
way to manage and model and understand the
permissions across your products. So
Alright. Yeah. Fantastic answer. So I think with
that, we've hopefully given everyone watching enough context
to understand
the old, the new, and now we can
guide them through some steps. I'll also just
show there's some content on the Offset YouTube
channel,
which was invaluable to me when I was
learning the SpaceDB, which is the session where
you built think it was the GitHub permissions
model video.
That is a if this video doesn't help
you, which I hope it does, go check
that one out later. So
I am going to share my screen, and
we will kick this off.
Alright.
No computer signal.
It'll pop up that it was, like, requesting
me to share my screen. I'm not sure
that was right. Well, I changed it over.
So it it should just be me now,
and here we go.
Perfect.
Alright. So this is offset.com/spacedb.
From here, you can learn more about how
to work with things,
understand the lexicon, and then there's a guide
over here to learn the basics,
as well as a few other useful pieces
of documentation for anyone working through learning in
SpaceDB.
It is, of course, open source, so feel
free to check out the repository.
Something that I also found useful is examples
repository,
particularly the schemas directory. It's good for understanding
how to model certain use cases.
And we also have the SpaceDB or the
offset
playground, which allows you to
run tests against the models and definitions that
you put together.
So given all of this, I'm hoping that
we can come up with some interest in
use cases
just to show people how to build that
model. Because, again, I'm not coming into this
completely,
you know, often with Rawkode Live is, like,
I've never heard of the project before. I've
heard of it. I've never played about it.
And we're supposed to be a little bit
further along.
So, hopefully, we can just
take some of my challenges. And for me,
the challenge was building the schema, the model,
understanding how to put that together rather than
interacting with the code and speaking to the
database and and querying things. So I really
want us to spend, not labor it, but
spend a bigger amount of time because your
people understand how to put that together. That
makes sense?
Yeah. I think that makes sense and it's
definitely the place you probably wanna spend the
most time. Conceptually,
I'm pretty sure most people that are, like,
jumping into this are gonna understand,
oh, okay. This is how you deploy something
on Kubernetes that's
cloud native and package it as a container.
And that's pretty much
all it takes to run SpiceDB.
It's mostly just
like, what's the value for you and how
are you modeling your domain? That's probably where
people want to learn the most and understand
the most. So totally agree. I think that
it's where the cognitive shift is. Again, we've
all you know, everyone
can't keep putting words in people's eyes. I'm
gonna assume most people have worked with permissions
are now back to some degree.
And I hope that they come into it
with their own use cases so we can
show them how to go from a use
case to build in the model, then we
can get into playing playing with it in
other regards. Nobody on this channel needs to
know how to do a Helm Deploy. Like,
we're way past that now. So at least
I hope we're 2025,
so fingers crossed.
Alright.
Now in the documentation, you do cover modeling
and concepts and stuff like this, and there
are examples here that we could
kinda lean into and show. And I think
maybe we just pick one and start with
that. Possibly just the I think the the
blog one here. Does that have a yeah.
Schema here. So maybe we can kinda work
through this, but then we can tackle it
and talk about maybe something that's a bit
more cloud native. And then I'll throw this
to the audience. Right?
If you don't give me a suggestion in
the next five minutes of something that you
would like to see modeled with the schema,
just to put, you know, Jimmy on the
spot, then we'll go with one of my
own things that I actually need for the
Rawkode Academy platform, and I can provide more
context on that as we go.
Now when people are adopting and they want
to start bringing SpaceDB into their infrastructure or
offset,
I think you kind of said it a
minute ago. Right? But the first thing we
need to have is that knowledge of the
domain. What are we building the model and
the schema
for to get started? And in this documentation
example, we talk about protecting the blog. So
I'm assuming the context is you're building a
website, it has some sort of articles,
and you have two different roles. Someone who
could read an article, someone who can write
an article, and maybe even as a third
where someone can edit an article that has
already been written or published. And we could
take this even deeper if we want to,
but we'll keep it superficial for now.
When you have that domain knowledge,
as rating your schema step number one for
adopting SpaceDB.
Yes.
Sorry about that. Yeah.
Alright.
I mean, I love talking to myself, but
a conversation sometimes works a little bit better.
So
oh, we can just get a run through
this. The the language, is this something that
people have seen before? Did I mean, I'm
assuming you just based loosely on JSON with
some typing information. That was the idea was
to make it seem somewhat familiar to people.
But I'm curious if there's anything that I
I mean, I
it's just based on something else that I
have no knowledge of. I'm curious. Yeah. I
I can kinda tell you the history of
this. It's actually really funny.
So inside the Zanzibar paper, they kind of
have their own kind of syntax
where they're kind of modeling the different,
object types is that's the the SpiceDB terminology
for this. And
we built, like, a custom parser for it
at first, and we're it was really slow
and we're like, this is such a weird
format. Why did they do this? It took
us, I forget how many months before we
realized it was just the protobuf text format
and we're
face palmed
because
Joey, one of my cofounders, literally
worked on Stubby and protobuf at Google for
many years, so he's super
deeply familiar with this whole tool chain.
But, yeah,
we basically realized, like, at Google they have
lots of tooling around ProtoBuff and just everything
is ProtoBuff,
but, like,
that's not really super ergonomic outside of Google.
So
we kind of squinted at how they were
doing things and kind of envisioned something that
was at least more user friendly.
And
we've actually seen a lot of other projects
that are kind of loosely in the same
space as SpiceDB
then adopt a very, very similar syntax, which
means I feel like we kind of like
knocked it out of the park in terms
of making something like understandable
and reasonable.
But no, this is kind of a custom
domain specific language,
kind of loosely inspired, like,
kinda just like c style, like languages.
But the idea is you're kind of defining
the different types of objects that live in
your system
and then you define relations between those objects.
So in this case, can see we we're
defining like a user, but then you you
need the users to exist so that when
you start talking about posts, you can say,
okay. There are readers of a post which
are users and there are writers of a
post which are users.
But you could define
any type of
object that you need to represent in your
kind of applications or your domain and then
use those, to create relations.
And then we have this distinction between a
relation and a permission. You can think of
a permission as like the end API
that you want applications to call into when
they want to check a permission.
So,
here in this kind of blog example, we
say permission read and you can see we
actually have this additional syntax.
You're not just saying permission read equals reader,
but we're actually talking about,
using the set semantics here to
define all the possible ways you could have
read access.
And basically what we're we're doing by saying
reader plus writer here is saying that if
you're a writer, you also inherit
the read,
permission.
So there is no scenario where someone should
be given,
write access where they don't also get read
access.
And by doing it this way, it's it's
actually super powerful.
You could actually make this even more powerful
if you say,
permission read equals reader plus write
and you actually reference the other permission, the
write permission
because
the the main advantage to doing that is
actually then if you change,
the definition for who gets write access,
that all propagates down to the read
permission definition.
So if you change,
how people can get write access to this
document, say you have like an admin or
something like that,
and you just updated the write permission to
say like, write is writers plus admins,
that would flow then all the way down
to the read permission if you defined that
in terms of the write permission.
So you kind of get like this really
natural inheritance and like, dry, like don't repeat
yourself syntax when you kind of modeled things
this way.
But yeah, the original Zanzibar syntax was pretty
confusing
and we kind of like distilled it down
to just kind of like very simple,
definitions of permissions and relations.
So I think that's like a a pretty
good high level description here. But, yeah, it's
totally inspired
just to, like, look familiar, but there really
wasn't much we could lean on in the
space beyond,
kind of the core data that
basically Google was using for in their protobufs.
Alright. Awesome.
Okay. So
I wanna make sure that I mean, that
that history
was great. That actually reveals a lot more.
I love those kind of simple questions where
you get a lot more of it. Like,
that was fantastic.
But, you know, as far as, you know,
people watching this, we've got definition, which you
said defines an object type. Right? So these
are the things that exist to entities perhaps
in your application or your whatever it is
you're building.
We then have the permissions. These are the
I'm assuming the lowest level of thing. You
have some ability to do something on some
object.
Again,
here is read and write. And then we
have the relations. I'm assuming, you know, we've
got relation reader, relation writer, we could have
relation owner or like you could build this
out to map to the domain of whatever
is that you're trying
to model.
Are all those is there any other, you
know, terms, lexicon that we're going to approach
as we start to model with SpaceDB that
people may need to be familiar with?
There are more advanced ones, but I think
for, like, this core kind of example of
just, the blog posts,
I think this is really all you need.
Okay.
So let me scroll down here and we
have the ability to see how to work
with the node APIs and even the ZCLI.
Maybe you could give the audience a bit
of understanding and what is the ZCLI
and and how should they and when should
they use it?
Yeah. So it's kind of unfortunate because we
had this command line tool that we named
Zed and then, like, the Zed editor came
out, like, a year later or something,
which
is just, like, way more I guess, like,
it's not that it's more popular, it's just
it's more applicable to more developers. Every developer
has every text editor installed on their machine,
but it's unfortunate naming conflict, but Zed is
our command line interface to interact with SpiceDB
clusters.
So the cool thing here is Zed is
kind of like a wrapper around our API,
in a CLI tool.
There's a bit more functionality than that, but
it's really nice if you just wanna like
poke at a SpiceDB instance or a cluster,
pull down some data, read it, manipulate it.
You don't actually have to like sit down
and write code, instead you can just kind
of use and and,
even write bash scripts if you needed to
using the ZCLI
to to poke at it. So all these
examples were kind of showing you how you
would implement it inside of a programming language,
which was typically how you would integrate with
your kind of applications in your product suite.
You would actually maybe not for a schema,
some people manage the life cycle of their
schema in like a CICD,
flow,
but,
most other things like actually calling check permissions
and and things like that,
folks are going to be writing that from
from inside their applications.
So,
the difference with Zed is,
it's kind of more of a sysadmin or
like ops tool for you to poke at
the cluster and kind of ask it questions,
debug it. We even have like really compelling
features like an explain flag that helps you
debug why a request was particularly slow.
So all the instructions in this guide also
show you how to use it using zed
if you don't wanna sit down and write
code in a programming language.
Perfect.
Alright.
Now
this says here, you know, we're talking about
migrations
and we have a schema. Obviously, these evolve
over time.
So
assuming I am vape coding my way through
some sort of schema here and I change
user and I say, you know what? That's
a very vague term to define what, you
know, some actor within my system is. And,
actually, what I wanna call them, I use
my own experience, like the Rawkode Academy has
learners. So I'm like, okay. Let's just search
and replace user to learner. I had go.
What are the gotchas that people should be
aware of, and how do we handle schema
evolution
when working with SpaceDB?
Yeah. So first off,
SpiceDB itself is basically gonna be doing tons
of validation around the data that's already written
to a SpiceDB and the schema. So if
you make a change, like rename
user to learner,
but you already have data written inside SpiceDB
that created users, for example, or associated users
with posts,
and you go to try to apply that
schema, SpiceDB is actually gonna warn you. It's
gonna throw up an error and say like,
hey, you're trying to do this thing, but
that would potentially leave
data you've written to SpiceDB dangling.
The idea being like it wouldn't be associated
with any objects in your schema, so like
that data would still be written but not
be used, which could be surprising if you
ever in the future wrote another schema
that created a user type and you forgot
that you had written data about users. Now
all of a sudden those that that data
would come alive and start changing permissions in
a way you probably didn't expect.
So we do lots of validation to make
sure you're not necessarily doing
anything surprising or doing something that might bite
you in the future.
That being said, there
are a lot of tricks.
I wouldn't say tricks. There's a lot of
things that, you can do in SpiceDB
that you really wouldn't be able to do
in a lot of other systems,
like redefining
a permission to be backwards compatible.
And
doing that kind of lets you iterate on
these schemas over time
and,
not necessarily break existing applications as you add
new logic,
and then slowly gives you the opportunity to
kind of like deprecate the old one. Oftentimes,
when you want to actually make a change,
it's it's often just a one line change
in the schema and you actually don't have
to touch code anywhere because you've centralized that
data and,
and all that logic of how folks get
access to something into SpiceDB,
your end applications, they're just kind of making
these API calls.
And, the more the more granular actually your
applications are to making these API calls so
they can do things like, can this API
key access this post?
By doing that,
you you
have all the freedom in SpiceDB to completely
redefine how API keys get associated with users.
Maybe they go through a service account transitory
through that. Maybe you didn't have that service
account at the beginning, but now you do.
But because your end application only asked about
the API keys access,
you can add that layer of indirection and
not have to touch any code in your
application because you were just focused on the
exact primitives you had at hand. You had
the API key and you had like the
post they were trying to access.
And then the other important thing to add
here, great example with users,
Spice TV doesn't necessarily prescribe how users should
look.
Inside
of Google and in the Zanzibar paper,
Google works out this assumption that they all
have the same of core identity provider,
and at Google, that service is called Gaia.
And at Gaia,
every
user boils down to a super big unsigned
in 64 bit integer.
Spice DB doesn't make that same assumption
because that's not how the real world works,
and we actually let you model very complex
users,
using the same primitives you would model, anything
else in SpiceDB.
So you could have like a really robust
system where users have a different login providers
and different credentials and different services accounts and
API tokens, and you can model all of
these things kind of custom to your end
use case. And then as long as your
application is asking like that last that last
primitive, that very bottom primitive, you can refactor
all that stuff, change it all, adopt a
new, identity platform, swap identity platforms
and, your application code just doesn't need to
change. So that was a lot of information,
but, yeah.
Basically,
we're we're giving you as many guarantees as
we possibly can as you iterate on these
systems because that's that's a lot of the
value is making sure that you're confident,
in these changes.
And a lot of folks end up basically
using
CICD around making changes to their their schemas.
And you can actually write test cases and
assertions and negative assertions,
and even kind of exhaustively generate all the
paths through the graph that space does driving
SpiceDB
to kind of discover any anomalies in a
system you've modeled. And because it's centralized, you
know that, like, everything is represented in that
one place rather than you kinda play, like,
whack a mole and see, like, what is
the subtle interaction between, like, microservices
a's permissions and microservices b. It doesn't matter
because they're all in the one central,
kinda schema for SpiceDB when you when you
do it this way. So
lots of information. Sorry about that.
Information is good. I mean, that's what people
are tuning in to learn and to understand,
you know. These things especially when you're, you
know, if you're at a stage in your
application where you're looking at SpaceDB and Zanzibar
and all these other things. Right? It's like
I mean, I hope a lot of people
are doing domain driven design. They understand their
domains. They understand their body context. They understand
everything with not everything, but, you know, there's
a good
a good baseline understanding of what is their
modeling. Because I do think that is really
important and it's gonna help them prevent, hopefully,
a lot of naive assumptions and errors down
the line. So, you know,
people are hopefully in the right trajectory. I
mean, I don't see WordPress adopting SpaceDB anytime
soon,
but, you know, more mature applications and enterprise
applications, this stuff is super important.
So we're now in a position where, you
know, we've got definitions of object types. We're
building relations. We're doing permissions,
but we actually have all we have so
far is schema. Right? There's no actual data.
And this is where we get into the
the ZCLI or, again, you can use any
of code examples, but you have to define
the relationships.
This is the ability to grant permissions
to these types within your systems with other
objects. And
and here's a, you know, nice simple example.
We just create a relationship between some post
with ID one, writer to user Emilia. I
mean,
I'm not assuming people here are gonna be
set and using the ZCLI to do this.
I hope you're doing this in code.
But what is or what have you seen
with people that are doing this and adopting
this? You know, assuming they're not in a
a greenfield project, they've got some sort of
existing
system and they have to do some sort
of bulk migration of permissions and entities to
SpaceDB. Is that something where the ZCLI is
gonna help them? Is it something where you
just expect them to write a script? Is
there preexisting tools? Like, how do people with
existing data and infrastructure and applications migrate to
a SpaceDB world?
Yeah. That's a super good question. I mean,
it's the user journey for most of kind
of the adopters for SpaceDB.
I think
mostly we recommend, and this is kind of
true almost for all technologies,
you probably shouldn't just overhaul
an entire system and just
lift and shift, pick up everything, put it
in the new thing,
the old thing. What you really want to
do is kind of make yourself familiar
with the newer system and kind of be
able to onboard
that technology
as like your team gets familiar with the
technology and kind of like levels up their
skills for operationalizing it and just understanding how
to use it.
So what we normally recommend is actually
focusing on one particular use case if you're
not a greenfield application that knows you need
this.
And that use case is probably something you
would struggle with to implement yourself. So maybe
a customer recommend or requires
that you build recursive teams. So in your
system, you need teams that can embed other
teams
and you don't know how deeply nested that
needs to go,
but you also don't know how you'd implement
that yourself. Maybe your
your SaaS app that's written on top of
MySQL and MySQL, unlike Postgres, doesn't have recursive
joins.
So if you were storing something inside your
database,
the kind of natural inclination there would be
like, okay. I would use a recursive join
to just keep arbitrarily
digging out and, kind of chasing foreign keys
to the same table.
But like if you have a database system
that doesn't support that,
how
would you even implement that? You would pull
that out in a logic maybe. A lot
of people get stuck,
on certain features like this.
And then that, I think those features are
the ones that are like a really good
opportunity to introduce a new technology like SpiceDB.
So you would say, okay. I'm just gonna
start with this one feature. What's the minimal
set of data that I need to get
to drive this feature?
And the interesting thing about SpiceDB is at
its core, it kind of works as a
graph database.
And how kind of graph databases work is
there isn't like a create a user in
a graph database. That's not really how it
works.
In graph databases, you just build these kind
of relations between things.
So
for example, the commands we have here for
Zed says,
we're associating
a user Amelia as a writer for post
one. There's no thing that we said where
we created Amelia.
There's no, like, create user Amelia. That doesn't
exist. Just the mere existence of Amelia of
a link basically existing in the system between
a post and Amelia is what makes Amelia
kind of alive in the system.
If Amelia wasn't didn't have any relationships whatsoever,
if you asked if Amelia has access, the
answer would just be no because there's no
data at all related to Amelia in the
system.
So
that aspect alone makes it so you actually
don't have to load as much data as
you think in a splice DB. There's no
thing where you need to be like, all
right, let's sync all the users into here
unless you needed some kind of attribute between
the users,
and something else represented.
So that cuts down a lot. The Zed
tool does have so there are bulk import
and export APIs in SpiceDB.
Zed does actually expose all that and gives
you kind of flags for, like, batching and
things like that. If you, wanted to kind
of export something into SpiceDB
really efficiently,
it's basically a batch script away.
But then some folks also just
kind of lazy load this stuff. So you'd
integrate it into your application and then when
that data is first necessary,
your application actually like write some data into
SpiceDB and it would kind of be like
a piecemeal migration. There's a lot of different
ways you can actually
do all this stuff, but I think it
depends on kind of how you're adopting the
technology
and what feature you're trying to drive.
So I hope that answered the question.
Yeah.
I believe it did. Definitely.
Alright.
I like that. It's kind of decoupled. Right?
But I think it also pronounced perfect. The
data is decoupled from the actual system.
You know, we have written and said, Emilia
can write to post one.
What is the
process then if I've been very silly in
my architecture and
users handle is their idea using permissions and
not some sort of UUID or good,
and then they have the ability in the
system to rename themselves.
Is there the ability is then for me
to speak to SpiceDB and say, please treat
user Emilia now as user
x.
So there there is not.
I could actually see
a way to move forward with that would
be, like, adding yet another layer of indirection
above user
and then create like a
I don't know, like an actual core user
and then you treat user as an alias.
So you
could work your way out of that situation.
There isn't like a mass rename
built into SpiceDB or anything like that.
That being said, we do recommend you use
kind of
not always GUIDs but like usually unique identifiers
here.
We definitely tell all of our customers you
shouldn't be storing any like PII or anything
like super super coupled to any of this
stuff.
It does it does make actually like as
a human interacting with things like on the
command line a little bit more annoying when
it's just, like,
all GUIDs,
basically. You just see the type and then,
like, a really big number or something like
that.
But
that being said, like, it is the right
way you should be modeling these things is
using kind of these core,
I guess things you think of as a
primary key in a database, like identifiers for
your different objects
so that you do have the freedom to
kind of rename these things because at
like the core, you really don't want kind
of metadata stored in your authorization system. That's
like for the end applications.
So you really don't care about usernames
when you're talking about permissions. If they're coupled
to usernames, it's actually really scary because
you have to consider, like, those renaming semantics
you were just talking about where, like, what
happens if someone, changes their name to someone
who, like, maybe deleted their account, but, like,
you didn't delete all the relationships associated with
it? If you rename someone, do they inherit
a whole bunch of data that, like, you
didn't intend? Right? So there's all kinds of
really scary edge cases we're trying to, like,
push you towards avoiding by saying, like, hey.
You should probably probably just use IDs for
everything over here.
Little little worse on the DevX side,
but, like, the trade off long term for
kind of the correctness of your system and
chances of you making a mistake that's security
critical go way down.
Yeah. I mean, if we identify the modalities
of people that are working with SpiceDB,
they're probably not gonna be set and using
the ZCLI for their day in, day out.
Like, it may be used as some sort
of query tool, but that lack of developer
experience with the IDs, I think, is acceptable
for a more scalable and longer term system.
So I think yeah. You know, we should
not be using document titles as our primary
ID, etcetera. I think we're, again, we're we're
past that, but you never know.
Alright. I think we kinda covered,
you know, this schema and working with the
ZCLI and how relationships work. I think if
we head over to the playground now, maybe
we can pick one of these examples and
find something that's
a bit more interesting to dive into more
of the the schema semantics and how this
works. Do you have a a personal favorite
from the example schemas that you would like
to kinda talk about?
I mean, probably scrolling up.
I mean, we kind of already talked about
the simple role based access control one.
Maybe the caveat one is an interesting one
to really dive into
because this
is kind of like a functionality
that
maybe the beginner wouldn't know exists in Spice
TV but is actually super, super critical for
a lot of different use cases.
You'll notice
in the definition that
you just pulled up, there is kind of
this definition
document.
We kind of already have seen something similar
to that, but you'll notice after relation
reader, we have this pipe
there. And so that's kinda similar if you're
familiar with TypeScript.
We actually let you kind of union type.
So, you could say, like, readers are users
or,
I don't know, API keys. You you can
actually make it so multiple types can be
assigned to the reader relation.
But what we're actually doing here is we're
saying it can be a user or it
can be a user with this particular caveat
named only on Tuesday.
And caveats are kind of a concept that
the team created. It's not a thing that
exists inside the Zansbar paper, we did collaborate
with Netflix on its creation,
for one of their use cases.
But it basically lets you,
kind of do more dynamic relationships
inside of SpiceDB.
This unlocks all kinds of kind of,
basically ABAC style use cases,
attribute based access control, the idea that you
can have dynamic attributes coming in as well
as basically to augment the data that's already
living inside of SpiceDB.
And then you can kind of execute some
logic
on that context that you're providing
to say yes or no whether or not,
a particular relationship,
living inside of SpiceDB is valid.
So,
that that's a really abstract,
way to describe it, but let me make
it a little bit more concrete.
Here we have a caveat named only on
Tuesday and it's really, really simple. You pass
in a string, which is the day of
the week, and if the string you passed
in equals Tuesday,
then the caveat evaluates to yes.
So when you write a relationship to SpiceDB
about,
basically
users,
you would include,
for
users with a reader on this document. So
when you're actually saying, okay, this user is
a particular reader
on this document,
you can also provide
context
for this caveat or associate this caveat with
the relationship.
And what that's gonna say is, okay, this
user
is going to have reader for this document,
but only if this caveat is true.
So that is going to require requesters
to provide the day of the week when
they do a permissions check that requires this
data.
So that makes it really, really powerful,
because you can kind of add all kinds
of dynamic aspects. You might say like this
person is allowed to do this thing, but
only if the IP address they're using to
connect is from a particular subnet. So it's
like from our private network, which means they're
on the VPN.
Right? You can encode all of this logic
now inside of SpiceDB and enforce that to
make,
the relationship stored in it true or false
depending on, like, completely variable context. That maybe
it doesn't make sense to save that data
inside of SpiceDB because it's changing too fast.
Like saving the IP address of a particular
user probably isn't a great thing to store
inside of SpiceDB because it's constantly changing.
So you probably just wanna provide that as
context if it is critical to your decision
making for authorization.
The other thing to note here is,
the caveat language, the thing we're using to,
kind of write day of week equals equals
Tuesday.
This is using cell. If you're familiar with
Kubernetes, this is the the policy language built
into Kubernetes.
I think it's probably the best way forward
when it comes to kind of policy
purely because
it is not Turing complete and we can
kind of guarantee based on,
what's written by parsing the syntax tree actually
how fast it's going to execute and then
it has bounded execution.
So unlike a lot of other kind of
policy languages
where you can just keep stacking policies or
you like really don't know how long something
is going to execute, we can actually put
limits in SpiceDB that say these policies have
to execute within this amount of like milliseconds.
So we can still guarantee that you're gonna
hit SLAs that you have, in terms of
latency for getting these responses back.
It was just a really, really powerful primitive,
for defining these policies
in a way that they're not gonna inhibit
you because kind of the stance that,
we at AuthZED have is if you can
represent it as data, it's way better and
by data, I mean relationships living inside of
SpiceDB.
It's preferable to store things as much as
possible as data because that data can be
indexed and you can query it in a
bunch of different ways.
That is a more powerful experience than having
to execute code to say yes or no
for something because if you wanted to say,
give me the list of all the users
that have access to this particular thing,
that means you would have to go through
every single user and execute a policy on
each and every single one to filter that
list if it was purely just being done
with a policy language versus if it's represented
as data, you can actually just query that
data and it's probably indexed in something like
SpiceDB where you can then just traverse
that, kind of how that data is laid
out on disk to determine what those users
are and just return them very quickly.
So,
we think it's a more predictable and more
reliable way to have everything be data driven
and then you just sprinkle on a little
bit of policy where you need it and
make sure it's bounded.
So that's kind of like the idea behind
caveats.
And
yeah, if you kind of like jump through,
you can see test relationships on the different
tabs at the top.
We kind of have put in some relationships
and you can see on the right hand
side there's the space for the actual caveat
name
and
you can write assertions about this or expected
relations.
But yeah, This UI
also, I just wanna to mention,
this whole UI is running both SpiceDB and
Zed just compiled to WebAssembly.
And then we kind of have a custom
UI built in Monaco,
very similar to our Versus Code plugin. So
this is kind of just like very similar
to a Versus Code plugin, just like running
purely in your browser, but we just took
everything and compiled it to WebAssembly to get
that to work. So it's real splice d
b running in in your browser. It's real
zed running in your browser to to to
do all this and drive this experience.
Wow. Very, very cool. Yeah. I
love following the WebAssembly thing right now. Just
seems to getting more and more powerful. I've
even seen something a couple of weeks ago
where someone compiled Postgres to run inside of
the browser, and you're like, why? But also
very cool. So
Yeah. What what's really neat about this is
because it's all real when you kind of,
like, hit the download button or export it,
that's all kind of portable. So you can,
like, work on something and iterate on the
playground, share it with, like, your coworkers, and
then when you're all good, you just, like,
export it and then load it right into
SpiceDB and you're good to go.
Okay. So let me
try and pivot this caveat example to one
of the use cases that I've got for
the Rawkode Academy. So I'm about to deploy
the ability to react to videos as you
watch them on the website.
However, I don't want fake reactions and fake
comments on the video. I actually want to
make sure that people have watched a certain
percentage of a video in order to thumb
it up, thumb it down, love heart, or
even comment and tell me, you know, how
annoying my audio is this week, which is
a very common complaint. So would I use
a caveat then to say, you know, has
watched,
you know, 50% or something like that? I
guess that would be like a PT and
then it takes a percentage
and that would be an integer or an
I'm not sure what the
I'm not sure. N number?
N
think it should have been. I think I
think you're good. Order is is the opposite.
I'm pretty sure. I'm I think it's, like,
the n percentage.
And because this is just salary, I can
say, alright, if it's greater than a 50.
So Yeah. If if I have this caveat,
I wanna make sure I understand this bit
because this bit is actually new to me.
I don't fully understand this. Right? So we've
got a
let's call it a video.
We've got people that are allowed to watch
a video.
I guess it's a watcher.
And and then messing up all your tests
as well. Right? But you have the ability
to watch a video if you're a watcher.
And what we're saying is that
all users can watch or users bug a
caveat. So the caveat is a piece of
data on the user,
an attribute, if you will. Right?
So is that Yeah. The the way to
think about this is, like, this is you're
expressing types right now. So you're saying that
you can assign either users with no caveat.
That's what the first thing to the left
of the bar is. That's just saying, you
could just assign a regular user to this
and they don't require the caveat. And if
you if you write that relationship,
that means that user doesn't care whether they're
at 50%
or not. They won't require that context when
you ask, like, are they a watcher or
not.
So that's one option. You could delete that
left everything left of the bar, like including
the bar,
and then that would just say, okay, every
single watcher, every single user you're going to
write here has to have this caveat associated
with it. Right?
Which means whenever you write any of them,
like, then,
you have to at runtime provide
the percentage
whether the
percentage is gonna be greater than 50 or
not. So,
if you write a relationship that is a
user,
with this caveat and then
when you pass in at runtime, say they're
they hit zero or, well, first of all,
let's say if you don't provide anything whatsoever,
zero context, it's gonna actually throw an error
and say, like, you need to provide me
a context if you want this to work.
And then you'll it will even tell you
specifically what you need to provide. It'll tell
you you're missing the percentage here.
And then
you would update your request and say, like,
okay. Here's my percentage. Basically, you're not even
gonna be able to run the permissions check
until you actually provide the context, which is
the the percentage.
Otherwise,
like, you just don't have enough information
to actually solve this this request
because what it's gonna do is it's gonna
basically find gather up all the users and
then what it has to do to evaluate
the users to say whether or not those
relationships are even worth considering is
plug in your context value, like your percentage,
and then it's gonna execute the caveat for
all of them and then it's going to
filter them based off of that result.
So, the other interesting thing just to note
with caveats is,
say you had multiple
parameters going into this caveat,
you can actually
partially evaluate them, so partially apply,
at different points in time. So you could
actually say,
when you go to write a user, you
could actually pre apply a percentage
and say, like, this is the permanent percentage
that's written to this user. I know they
hit 50,
so they're good forever.
And for future requests to them, I don't
need to provide the context, so I'm just
gonna write
when I say this user is a watcher,
I'm also gonna write and say, like, and
the context includes that they already hit 50%
on the on the video.
So,
you actually have this this kind of duality
of like when you care to provide the
context,
some of it can be at the time
at which you write the relationship and some
of it can be at the time you
actually make the query to say, like, I'm
checking this permission.
It's really powerful when you start kind of
pre reapplying some,
parameters to the caveats,
but that's probably more advanced of the use
case.
Alright. So what I'm taking away from this
is that this is a horrible way for
me to build my 50% thing. I should
not do it this way because it would
require for every single user that I create
to have
a caveat,
which I then provide a value at runtime,
which doesn't make a lot of sense. So
realistically, if I were modeling this,
I would probably just want to make sure
a user has watched a certain amount of
content and then consider them trusted and give
them a new role, and then they have
the ability to comment and thumbs up or
something like that. Yeah. That's a good way
to do it. But if you really wanna
do, this is actually totally fine. There are
trade offs associated with it. It totally works.
But, yeah, I would definitely lean towards
some other kind of flag you can set
on the account to say, like, alright. Yeah.
This this one's legit.
Yeah. So I don't mean to drag you
onto a livestream just to get my support
calls answered. But, you know, let's tackle one
more use case. Right? Let's imagine
I publish a course and everyone gets general
availability access on a certain date. However, I
want to give trusted community members access two
weeks before. Is that something you would model
as data using
SpiceDB?
Yeah, absolutely. There's another feature and it gets
used similar
to
where you're using the caveat. If used as
part of the types
that you define on a relation, you can
actually use this feature we call the wildcard,
which is effectively the idea of public or
not. It says,
when the wildcard
is written to this value, so the wildcard
is actually, it's both a type and it's
a relationship that you can write. So,
the idea is,
you can say relation watcher user or
wildcard user.
And
the reason why you do that is you're
saying like, do I want this relation
to be allowed to use the wildcard?
So
fundamentally we let you kind of use the
type system to gate what things are allowed
to actually be wild carded or not, but
then when you you can actually write a
relationship that says basically user star is allowed
to access this thing. And so that means
any user, any user you provide whatsoever is
going to just get true for that particular
relation.
They're they're totally good. Sorry if there's a
little background noise. But
basically
what you could do then is say, all
right, my trusted users, I'm going to add
them by name or by ID, right? You're
going to add them individually to give them
real access and then when your date that
you're launching
publicly
hits,
then you would write the wildcard relation and
say like, all right, gates are open now,
everyone can access this. It doesn't matter whether
you're in the kind of private list before
And that would be like a really good
way to to model kind of like that
early access.
Okay. So, you know, people are working on
CMS systems,
etcetera, and they want an article to go
live at a certain date,
they would set up some sort of automation
that runs on a cron every hour. Okay.
With the go live date is now a
hit, you're writing to SpiceDB and saying this
is now available
to everyone. That is the the secret sauce
there
rather than develop caveats and pass in the
date for every request. So that seems like
it could be.
Absolutely.
Yeah. Because the caveats, the other thing just
consider with them is like, they kind of
live forever.
Like, once you write a relationship that is
caveated, that caveat will live with that relationship
forever. So if you do something like a
date and it's gonna have an expiration,
for example,
there's like no
process going through and like that understands the
custom cell code that you've written that says
like, oh, this will never this caveat, it
will never evaluate to true ever in the
future. So that's like kind of on the
user to say like, all right, this this
doesn't make sense anymore. I would have to
go in and delete all these or like
replace them all with non caveated versions,
because there is this trade off where like
you're gonna have to evaluate the caveat going
forward.
And like basically to solve that for the
most common use case
and more,
maybe not the most recent, but maybe two
versions ago of SpliceDB,
we actually released first class support for expiring
relationships,
which was one of the, most common usages
of caveats.
Users basically one wanted that to be way
more performant because it is so common and
for us to kind of like SpaceDB to
do the internal garbage collection to say like,
okay, like this relationship,
it expires on this date after that point
in time, it's no longer relevant, which means
you should just delete it. So SpiceDB should
just go through and kind of delete all
the expired
relationships.
And we can do that because it understands
expiring relationships and not like the custom caveat
code that you've written.
So now that super common use case is
built in and really, really optimized and there
are some users for some use cases that
are just using all expiring relationships
and just, like, constantly kind of retouching
those relationships to keep them alive over time.
But they have, like, this default case where,
like, if nothing were to happen, like, this
per all these permissions would just totally cease
to exist anymore,
which is really, really powerful and interesting use
case.
Yeah. That's fantastic. I had no idea about
that feature, but I'm definitely interested in playing
with that. So I'm assuming
when I'm using, say, the Node. Js SDK,
the Go SDK, and I create that relationship,
there's just metadata. I say expire in July,
'90 days, whatever, and that just is all
handled for me automatically.
Yep. Absolutely. And it's actually, like, a really
subtle thing because
notoriously distributed systems and, like, clocks
are not, like, friends is the best way
to put that.
In distributed systems, you really have to use
kind of events and the ordering of events
to determine things and causality to kind of
understand how the system works overall.
You can't just, like, look at a clock
because not everyone's clocks are synced and there's
things like leap seconds that can totally just
destroy,
a lot of your intuition around kind of
time and the ordering of things.
Fundamentally,
expiring relationships actually is associated with time though,
so there's kind of like this this friction
where these features are kind of at odds.
So we do the best we can to
kind of like push that down in the
way that makes the most sense rather than
like folks kind of like providing time from
like their app servers and like the app
servers are totally out of sync with like
SpiceDB. So we try to based on kind
of like what your data storage backend is
for SpiceDB,
we try to do like the best possible
thing there to make all this work. But
I just wanted to add that caveat,
because I think a lot of the distributed
systems folks would be like, something
about that doesn't seem right, if you're kind
of like using wall clocks for for some
of this stuff.
But, yeah, everything else in SPICE TP is
all kind of under the hood using event
based kind of vector clocks as typical distributed
systems would.
Alright. Awesome.
I want us to kinda explore the the
test relationships and assertions before we finish. I'll
be very brief with this last question then.
But you have mentioned, you know, clocks and,
you know, distributed systems, just vector clocks and
all these fancy things.
But let's talk about caching.
Now, if I'm building the system and say
I am I have an expiry relationship,
whether that's minutes, hours, whatever. Right? There's something
here that has to expire and I'm sending
a request to SpaceDB,
is it normal practice to say, okay, I'm
going to trust this for a percentage of
time as the expiration passed back with the
the request. Is that something I can figure?
Or would you just say that the performance
of SpaceDB
and, you know, the domain that is in,
which is, you know, security and permissions,
you should never catch. Like, what are your
thoughts on scaling and operating this thing as
I build out my system?
Yeah.
A good way to think of, like, what
SpliceDB even fundamentally is, is it's a really
sophisticated
distributed cache.
So kind of, we call it a database,
but it's a little bit different from a
lot of other databases. It's probably like closest
to like Redis in this sense in that,
Spice TV itself to kind of hit your
low latency kind of authorization requirements. Right? If
we like take a huge step back,
before you do any work on any of
your API servers, like you first have to
check a permission to see if the user
is allowed to do the thing,
which means
before you do any work, have to do
this.
And then you also have to consider there's
gonna be a network opt to the service.
So there's gonna be like at least one
or two milliseconds where you like reach out
to Display TV and ask it for something.
And already,
depending on a whole bunch of use cases,
maybe you want, maybe your SLA is like
ten milliseconds and we've already used two to
talk to Spice TV. Right? So basically Spice
TV's goal is to keep as much as
possible in memory,
ready to be served directly back to the
user, to the application
basically as quickly as it possibly can.
That being said, we keep as much as
possible in memory to do that and
then
what
the structure of kind of SpaceDB looks like
is we break down requests recursively
into kind of structural
kind of traversals through a graph
and cache
partial evaluations
of the graph and how you kind of
travel through that graph.
And so, like, if you have two permissions
checks and structurally they share some of the
same data they have to, like, go through,
so say you had, like, the reader permission
and then the writer permission from the blog
post earlier,
but the writer permission was also,
sorry. The the reader permission was also defined
by talking about the writer permission. Right? It's
also checking writers.
If you did a permissions check on writers
and then you did a permissions check on
readers,
half of the permissions check for the reader
would already be cached
because you already looked at all the readers
for that particular or sorry. You already looked
at all the writers for that particular thing.
So that means half of the work of
figuring out whether someone has permission was already
kind of preloaded and pre cached in SpaceDB
by the time you did that. So,
we're doing a lot to keep as much
kind of in memory lazily,
kind of as you request things
to kind of maximize memory usage, but then
also like make sure that cache hit rates
incredibly high.
The really nice thing about all this stuff
is it's kind of temporal.
So, after like maybe two hours, like, that
old permissions data, probably never gonna get queried
again, so we can actually just evict that
stuff from memory. So we're we're not necessarily,
like, hanging on to stuff indefinitely in memory.
So we can actually be pretty lean as
to, like, what our memory footprint is while
trying to keep as much in memory as
possible. So if your question is like, should
I be caching these things? I would say
the most sophisticated cache you would already have
is literally SpiceDB.
So if if you're kind of having issues
where you want something to be cached, what
you can do is just deploy a SpiceDB
more close to that particular endpoint.
So say like you are running SpiceDB in
one particular region,
in a cloud provider, but then you have
this one use case where like maybe you
have, like,
a hundred thousand queries per second. You might
actually wanna just dedicate another SpiceDB cluster just
sitting right in front of that. The same
shared data, it's all using the same, canonical
data and relationship storage,
but this one is just running directly for
that one use case. So all of the
caching
built into SpiceDB itself is just gonna be
focused on that one particular use case and
optimizing that one. So there's definitely different architectural
ways you can deploy SpiceDB to hit your
cache
hit goals.
But I don't think that
writing a
naive cache in front of the service is
probably going to
include all of the
semantics you need to encapsulate consistency and the
correctness
of the permissions
because if you think about it a stale
permission,
basically making an authorization decision based off of
a stale permission is a security vulnerability.
So, like, this is some kind of scary
critical data. Like, you you really don't wanna
try to, like, just use naive,
kind of caching,
mechanisms and especially when people can revoke permissions
kind of dynamically throughout the whole system.
Alright. I feel like I just got into
trouble, but that was totally worth it. So
thank you for for covering all that. That's
a super fair question. A lot of people
ask us about that. But, like, once you
understand what Spice TV is doing, you're like,
oh, okay. Yeah. I wasn't gonna do better
than that.
Yeah. I mean, we could go into the
whole cluster and topology and the best way
to architect this, but we are very short
in time and I don't want us to
to kinda run over. So maybe that's a
a session for another day or maybe people
should just check out offset.com
and and use the managed model. Because I
mean, that's just a lot easier.
But we'll talk about that when we finish.
So
we I've broken the relationships by changing the
entire schema of a model now. So, you
know, in order to show how these work
and how people can do some validations, I'd
like to update our tests and our sessions
to reflect what we're now doing with users,
videos, watchers, the watch permission
even if we don't use the caveat. So
we've got some video here. We've got a
watcher.
I can just type in this like a
spreadsheet, which is lovely.
I'm updating the relations. So what we're seeing
here is that we have some sort of
type user that
has a watcher relation to a document. Now
we don't have documents.
We made this a video.
So I'm assuming I'm fixing this. Please let
me know if I Yeah. You are. You
are. Some things are turning green. It's throwing
different errors. The nice thing is there's kind
of autocomplete all built into this stuff too.
You saw, like, video autocompleted.
Another thing just to note in the top
left corner, like right below where it says
schema, there's kind of this toggle right now
it's on like the grid kind of Excel
mode, but you can also hit like the
angle brackets, which is going to put it
in text format. And so say you wanted
to make like a ton of changes all
at once, you can actually use kind of
the find and replace shortcuts in Code right
here, like kind of mass, like bulk change
some things. So you could do, like, find
and replace on, the only only on Tuesday
and replace it with, your
your,
caveat for watchers being over 50%.
Alright. That was very helpful because I was
able to then switch from the watch permission
from the relation. So if we pop back
here, we should be green, which means that
Fred and Tom can both watch videos on
SpaceDB and Kafka.
If you look at the bottom too, there's
there's this kinda check watches
at the very bottom that's kind of going
off. And so if you kinda you can
drag that bar a little bit further up
and you can see more, I believe.
Maybe not.
This is saying watch is the name of
the permission and not the relation.
Oh, so I actually That means watchers. Yeah.
Yep.
Alright. Let's just update my schema.
Watcher.
No. That made it worse.
Ah, okay. Because of the like because I
changed the schema. Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. You
could just change that to just user if
you want and to just drop the caveat
altogether. We don't need to use that caveat.
Right? So now we've got this wonderful feedback
loop. Right? I'm evolving
my schema.
I've got data,
which we can look at in multiple fashions
to understand what is going on here. We
then have these assertions,
so we can actually run these. They should
fail now. Right? So
it's not even validating because we don't have
documents anymore. So
let's say document
and video.
And if we don't have the first doc,
we have the space d b
and Kafka.
And then we'll get into the
the differences here in just a moment. Let
me see if I can get the validation
to pass first.
And then we don't need any
caveats. We're not playing with those at the
moment.
So
is oh, view.
Watcher.
Yeah. Then I think you got some
quotes at the beginning of
line two and seven. You've got, like, a
single quote at the very beginning there. I
recently switched my keyboard to one that has
these new magnetic switches, and it's very eager
to type now. So yeah.
Alright. What did I get wrong now? So
filter validate. We've got some sort of problem
and it's saying a relation or permission to
exist.
Yeah. So this is actually telling you that
the the assertions themselves are failing. So what
you've written is is totally valid, but it's
telling you that, hey, I actually am looking
to see if user Tom is a watcher
and they are not.
And the reason that is is
because
I don't know. Because Tom is a watcher
on Kafka and not SPOTCP. Yeah.
Alright. So we switched this.
This is cool because now we're we're seeing
how this works. Alright? So let's return it
again, and this bit's okay. But now we've
got a cert caveated. So we don't have
caveats, but we can build specific test cases
to check that the caveats do pass when
they are applicable. So I will remove this.
And then we have a final one, which
is to assert false.
Yeah. This is saying that Tom is is
definitely not a watcher on SpliceDB.
And if we recall correctly, we never wrote
a relationship that gave Tom a watcher on
SpiceDB,
only Fred.
Alright. So why am I getting
is this just an old failure? Or Yeah.
You're just on the last validation run tab.
So because the last one succeeded, it's just
showing you old errors. That's specifically what that
is for.
Alright.
Yeah. And then This this tab, this last
tab, expected relations, I actually love this tab,
but I think most people struggle to understand
what it says.
This one is literally saying
the of the lines where the squiggles are
right now, like one and and four.
You you basically write these and then you
say,
please tell me all of the users that
have access to this permission.
And then if you hit compute and diff,
that button on the right,
it's actually showing you a diff of, like,
what's gonna change. Like, it ran through all
the data you had in the graph, and
it determined
that for the video Kafka,
there's only one watcher, and that's Tom. And
then it even tells you why. It's because
there is a direct relationship written where Tom
has specifically
given video Kafka watcher.
So if you imagine you have something more
complicated, this is gonna generate a giant kind
of full exhaustive list of how everyone got
access to everything.
And the nice thing of having this kind
of, like, diffing syntax is you can kind
of have what you assume to be true
and then what the computer ultimately finds as
reality,
and then it's just gonna highlight very specifically
the differences so that you can find any,
like, oops. I definitely didn't think about that
or, like, this user shouldn't have access to
that.
And you can imagine this is incredibly powerful
when you have, like, a really complicated model
or you're modeling your whole kind of product
portfolio
because now you know that, like, your system
is actually bulletproof. Like, you've walked through
all the possible, like, ways folks could get
access to things and exhaustively at least.
I recommend folks don't, like, handwrite these, but
just, like, review what ones are generated to
make sure that, like, your model is actually
representing the thing in your head and, like,
react like, reality where rubber meets the road
is is actually what you think it is,
and, no one has access to a particular
thing that they they shouldn't.
Nice. What I like here is that I've
looking for a video called Tom, which now
doesn't exist. So now we have no Tom
video watchers. But I'm assuming if I just
come in here and say SpaceDB
and then compute is gonna tell me that
Fred. Yeah.
That's awesome. I like that.
Yeah. It's super cool. I feel there there
isn't really like a good explanation written somewhere
that's like, this is exactly how you use
this tab. But holy holy crap. That's like
super, super powerful.
Yeah.
So I think we've covered a lot. Right?
You can generate schemas, build relationships,
make assertions,
and then you have expected relations at the
other end. This becomes a complete test suite
for the data that is your permission model
across your entire application. And, you know, there's
a bunch of schemas here and there's also
the schemas and the examples repository. So I
encourage people just to go and play with
this. You know, I didn't have to run
any commands my machine. I don't have to
run any Docker containers. The playground was just
sat there ready to let us explore
and learn,
which is invaluable. And now that I know
it's all done with WebAssembly with a real
space DB, it's just made it a little
bit cooler. So awesome.
Yeah. The other thing I'd just add here
is it's almost the exact same code that
runs inside the Versus Code extension. So also
if you wanna do those stuff locally, like
maybe you don't you don't trust like this
cloud hosted play.allsaid.com.
The Playground itself is open source, you could
just run your own hosted instance, or you
could just do it all inside Versus Code
in your own editor.
So
Sweet.
Alright. I'm gonna pop us back over to
big face mode, and we can
finish this off. So I really appreciate you
just you know, that's been, an hour and
a half of your time to sit here
and and just cover what I'm sure is
is really simple basic stuff for you, but
I hope this is valuable to people that
are looking to improve their permissions game, adopt
SpiceDB,
and just, you know, take their application to
that kind of next level, more cloud native
and better than naive assumptions. Because we've all
done, you know, permission one, user one, user
two, permission two columns and databases, and we
know it's wrong. But there's never been,
I feel,
an easier way to do it than there
is today with space to be. So I
really, again, appreciate your time and thank you
so much for joining me.
Do you wanna
just take a couple of minutes to tell
us, you know, is SpaceDB finished? Is Offset
finished? What's coming next? What challenges? What problems
are you solving next? And what should people
look forward to?
Yeah, mean, all software is never finished, right?
Software has to kind of like live and
breathe just like people. There's always going to
be folks kind of working on
maintaining it and adding new features
that customers require.
Like I said, just two
versions ago, we launched a pretty major feature
like the expiring relationships that fundamentally changes how
a lot of people use SpiceDB.
So
like that clearly means we're not done, SpiceDB
isn't done. Is it production ready and used
by some of the largest companies on the
planet? Yes. So it's probably
good enough for a lot of use cases
that you would consider it for,
but I would say there's
always kind of work in progress around kind
of developer experience and making sure these things
operate
how
humans want them to operate.
So a lot of other kind of authorization
solutions are focused on solving kind of authorization
for like one app, but SpiceDB is kind
of a
solution
that's kind of targeting your platform team running
this across a product portfolio or across your
whole business.
So to that end, that means we're actually
integrating with a lot of different teams. There's
like often a platform team operating SpiceDB at
their business and then there's app developers integrating
their products with SpiceDB.
And
we kind of have to make all these
folks have better experience user experience and
and an experience that they can kind of
collaborate with each other.
So a lot of,
the focus in the open source more recently
has been around taking
schema snippets like,
what we were just kind of working on
and being able to package those up and
share them.
And that way, if you had a really
big deployment and you wanted to kind of
like break down your schema and have this
team own this portion of the schema,
and write tests for that and understand that.
And then this other team owns this portion
of the schema. And then when you apply
that to SpiceDB finally, like it combines them
all together, runs all the tests, make sure
that there's, like, a comprehensive,
kind of,
correct schema and migration path to that new
schema.
And and I think that, like, this kind
of
workflow around kind of folks collaborating both internally,
but also externally.
So say you build a SpiceDB integration with
your open source project, it'd be cool if
you could package that integration with a schema
package as well so that anyone that wants
to use that can just, like, import this
part of the schema into their schema, and
now they can run this other kind of
integration tool and get it all for free
inside of their,
inside their SpiceDB deployment.
So we're kind of playing with, a lot
of that, like the packaging space right now
to see if we can enable, like, a
really nice, integration story
both internally across teams, but externally across software
projects.
And all that's open source and, folks can
play with play with it today. Right now,
it's built into Zed, but in the future,
we're looking to build it directly into SpiceDB.
So there's an issue on Zed where,
kind of documents the whole thing that folks
can use to get started with. And then
there's just flags built into zed to start
playing with it today.
Yeah. That would be a really awesome feature
because most people's domains are not novel. Right?
We're all solving the same problem to some
degree. So why not reissue reuse and reshare
some of this logic? I love that. That's
a great idea.
Alright. Any last words before we say goodbye?
Don't build your own authorization. That's not that
is like my number one thing. I end
all my talks, like any kind of public
engagements
with that. And like SpiceDB,
it's a really cool system.
Obviously, think it's cool because I built it,
but maybe it's not the right solution for
where you are as a business.
But if there is one lesson I've learned
throughout this whole thing, diving into the authorization
space when my background kind of wasn't that
before as pure distributed systems,
it's just that folks should not be building
it themselves.
Folks today,
they wouldn't dream of building a custom database
for every single kind of SaaS app that
they build. They know that they shouldn't be
building their own database,
but there's just as much research and authorization.
All that research started around the same time
as database research,
but folks still think they can go out
and, like, build a custom authorization model that's
gonna solve the problem for themselves,
with no, like, experience or backing or research
whatsoever.
So I just think that's, like, a huge
gap right now in the industry that, like,
this mindset needs to change.
Folks need to realize that they should be
kind of using foundational tools to help them
model this stuff. Whether that tool is placed
to be or not, that remains to be
said. That's your decision,
but you should go out and look at
SpiceDB and maybe look at other alternatives
so that you don't kind of build yourself
into a corner
with your own kind of custom logic code
that no one else can help you with
because you invented that. So
Awesome. Alright. Again, I really appreciate your time.
Thank you so much for joining me. I
hope you have a wonderful morning,
evening, lunch, whatever it is where you are,
and I'll speak to you again soon. And
to everyone watching, have a great day. Thank
you.